what if the computer was a beautiful
object some of you want to look at and
have in your home and what if instead of
it being in the right hands it was in
everyone's hands we'd be talking about
the most tectonic shift in the status
quo I'm begging you to manage
expectations have I ever let you go
every single goddamn time then undo your
Apple stock was worth 441 million
dollars and your daughter and her mother
are on welfare she's not my daughter
you must be able to see that she looks
like you we will know soon enough if you
were Leonardo da Vinci or just think you
are you're the only one who sees the
world same way I do no one sees the
world the same way you do everyone is
waiting for the mag what are people
going to do with it it's an abstract
they're gonna do that you're issuing
contradictory instructions you're
insubordinate to make people miserable
the board the least you're no longer
necessary to this company i sat in a
garage and invented the future because
the artists lead and hacks ask for a
show of hands what you make isn't
supposed to be the best part of you when
you're a father that's what's supposed
to be the best part of you I'm the only
one who knows that this guy is someone
you invented
is there a plan the plan will deal
itself to you when you're ready to see
it
come back of the superstore co-founder
Steven jobs these days seat job is
returning to Apple
to most significant events in the 20th
century the Allies win the war and this
you